(upbeat music)
- Hello there, I'm Joey Graceffa.
- And I'm Rosanna Pansino,
and we are hanging out at BuzzFeed today.
We are gonna be answering some questions
about our first of multiple things.
You go first, you go
first, you have the jar.
- Okay.
Let's see.
First time realizing you were famous.
- Ooh.
- Oh this is,
it wants me to be cocky, I see.
There was this crazy time
I was at a stoplight.
- Okay.
- And I was in my car--
- I'm imagining this.
- And my window's down,
I'm like blasting Selena Gomez.
And all of a sudden, one
of those Star Tours vans
pulls up right next to me
and this girl recognized me.
All of a sudden, the whole van is like
looking over, taking photos, and I'm just
wanting to enjoy my Selena Gomez moment.
I was so embarrassed.
- The first time I noticed
things were changing,
I was at a Chipotle.
- Oh.
- I was outside,
eating a burrito, and
someone got very excited
and started videotaping me, and came over
and said can we get a picture?
And I was like, sure, but I was like
things are changing.
- Yeah.
- First thing you do when you wake up.
I stumble to the bathroom,
(laughing)
and I go to the bathroom.
Does that count?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I always check my phone first.
Who texted me?
I need to check my emails, I
need to check my social media,
anything crazy happen, I
need to know first thing.
First big purchase as a YouTuber.
Probably my house.
I think--
- Same.
- Yeah.
- I grew up, like, not ever really having
like, a stationary home,
so the fact that I was
able to support myself
by doing what I loved and like create
like a home for myself
was just a crazy moment.
- First job.
- First job-ulation.
- First job, I've had
so many oddball jobs.
Waitress, barista, dog walker,
I was a teacher for
awhile, I've done it all.
- I stocked ice cream
trucks, which sounds fun--
- Sounds really fun.
- Right.
But I had to go inside a
freezer in the middle of summer,
like I wanted to be out,
enjoying the sun, but no.
I had to spend my summer inside a freezer.
- We're killing these questions.
- I know.
- We got it so good.
(gasping) First (kissy sounds).
- Kissy kissy.
- First kiss.
My first kiss was in middle school.
It was at my first
middle school dance.
- Scandalous!
- (laughs) I know!
- Middle school?
- Yes and his name was Matt
and he was so cute, he was a skater.
He skateboarded.
We kissed to a slow song,
it was a Boyz II Men.
- Was it at a dance or something?
- Mm-hmm school, middle school slow dance.
- I was way too scared to
kiss anyone in middle school.
I was actually 20 years old
when I had my first kiss.
- Not-uh!
- Yes.
It was actually at VidCon
that I got my first kiss.
- No!
- Yes.
- It was at VidCon?
- Oh my gosh--
- I know.
- That is so funny.
- It was so scandalous.
as well.
- Over there in Anaheim.
- Yes.
Who was your first celebrity crush
from childhood slash teenhood?
- Oh what about JTT,
Johnathan Taylor Thomas?
- Yes, bitch oh my god.
- Yes!
- As a secret, closeted gay, I agree.
- He was so cute!
- So cute.
First cellphone?
Mine was I think one of the
first cellphones every invented,
was the Nokia phone.
I'm pretty sure--
- I remember those!
- That was the first one.
- And you could put
different colors on them?
- Yeah, the cases at the mall.
- I had the Nextel, the
one where you push a button
and it was like--
- The walkie-talkie!
- A walkie-talkie.
- Yes!
I had one of those, too.
- I loved it.
- That was like my second cellphone.
I kind of miss that,
just the chirp, chirp.
Hey.
- Me, too.
- First YouTube crush?
- First YouTube crush.
- Oh, Anthony from Smosh, 5,000%
- You and him have gorgeous hair.
- Well I like use his hair--
- Like the two of you
are like--
- For inspiration
for the longest time.
I would go into a hair
salon with his picture
and be like I want this.
- I had a crush on YouTube and
then I started dating them.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- That's everything.
Alrighty, well I hope you guys enjoyed
this little first time video.
Again, I'm Joey Graceffa.
- And I'm Rosanna Pansino.
- I hope you guys go
check out my new show,
Escape the Night season
three with me and Ro.
It's pretty insane, so you
should definitely check it out.
- Yes.
- Every Wednesday at 11
on YouTube Premium, or
just go to my channel.
- Yes.
- It'll be there.
- Thank you BuzzFeed
for having us, buh-bye!
- Bye!
(upbeat music)